jean thomas bernard bonsoir bonsoir
première question plus simpliste mais
seconde à nos besoins en 2022 est ce
qu'on doit lancer une construction
possédant pas avant 15 ans qui seraient
prêts
ce qui sur le thème présentement ça me
ferme c'est le 3000 mégawatts de de
théolier bon sur l'éolien c'est
l'énergie alors que l'hydro québec et au
manque de capacité donc ça semble pas
très utile pour le moment un barrage
évidemment ça fournit d'énergie et de la
capacité alors qu'est ce qui aurait
changé que l'os apparaîtrait plus urgent
de construire barrage alors que dans les
derniers rapports de hydro y ont deux
n'était pas vraiment l'accent là-dessus
commandes madame bachelot a indiqué jos
que changer le dans l'ic d'amener boîtes
de vache tu sais quand l'énergie c'est
toujours abouba ce qui a changé c'est
l'explosion du prix du gaz naturel
chassard à vis de voir ça peut rendre
l'hydroélectricité attrayantes sur le
marché américain en particulier puis
aussi à peut-être des entreprises qui
voudraient se relocaliser ici parce que
effectivement ailleurs le plus accès
donc ça pourrait dit doit être justifié
que politiquement
l'actionnaire seuls les principales à
fait seul et unique d'hydro-québec 10 à
hydro-québec
accélérer le pas je veux voir des
projets concrets sur la table si
quelques mois pour production d'ici une
dizaine d'années je pense qu'il faut
regarder ça oui de façon un peu plus
serré la com dédié il n'y avait pas
urgence là puis
des des sodas ce marché de l'énergie e
on en a vu leur le losc on a lancé le
projet la romaine il ya pas si longtemps
c'était cet argument là bondi à écouter
on veut s'adresser aux changements
climatiques
les nordistes année
diderot on va être des voisins qui
pourront leur en forme est méritée
pendant tous ces périodes-là à mieux je
cours des derniers mois le prix de
l'électricité était très faible parce
que le prix du gaz naturel étaient très
faibles commencé dans le dernier rapport
trimestriel d'hydro-québec ont déclaré
des profits faramineux
vous dit oui à la question vous êtes à
ma question jean thomas bernard gousse
est oui le contexte est favorable pour
qu'on regarde ça vraiment de plus près
qu'on relance la construction de
nouveaux ouvrages qu'on garde ça c'est
bon l'autre question qui découle de
celle là où c'est quoi les rivières qui
ont du potentiel on a préparé une carte
non on va plus tout les nommés en un
certain non mais on up vous allez voir
la carte est-ce qu'on reprend l'on voit
tout temps aux grandes baleines sur
l'arrivée à granby est ce qu'on reprend
sa d'après vous oublie qu'on veut aussi
qu'on l'installé ouvrages dans les deux
projets qui pour l'un serait qu'on serre
et le dans l'immédiat petit mécatina qui
était déjà mentionné dans les plats le
de monsieur charest qui avait amené le
développement de même puis aussi google
qui est au labrador sable il y avait
déjà eu une en adaptant monsieur
bouchard de cette aubaine ce site
de 1300 mégawatts donc je pense qu en
terme de deux possibilités de
développement assez rapidement ça c'est
les deux ch et donc de riz vient qui
ceux qui prennent originaux labrador
petit mécatina qui dès sa côte d'or la
haute côte nord et ça vous dit hugo la
ln si on s'entend avec avec terre-neuve
donc grande-baleine aol oublie celle là
c'est un projet plus gros ça on parle de
3000 300 mégawatts alors que petit des
cas sinon ce serait peu près semblable à
la romaine
puis aussi il faut dire que le projet de
grand talent et 9 c'était mêle mal
terminée il n'y a pas eu de
développement hydro avait déjà dans
l'acien
500 millions de dollars pour faire les
études préalables sa propre du bon quand
on fait un barrage monsieur thomas
évidemment qu'un bassin et donc on
retient l'eau on veut de la pression
qu'on veut faire tourner des turbines
donc est-ce que vous voyez des défis
environnementaux
gigantesque et défis quant aux relations
et aux accords qu'il faudra avoir avec
les peuples autochtones
disons pour ce qui est de petit casino
bon évidemment c'est un contexte très
proche de celui de la romaine évidemment
il faudra s'attendre avec les premières
nations et elle valoir leur point de vue
là donc
de ce côté là ce n'anticipe pas de
difficulté majeure
c'est pas une rivière qui a été visé
particulièrement pour ses autres
attraits comme les aspects de stx quand
même très éloignées ça et s'apprêtait
particulièrement bien de ce côté là que
d'autres guerres autour de l'excellent
qui pourrait développer mais qui semble
plus mais je suis dit vous êtes c'est
plus petit que grande baleine mais étant
plus petit cet ouvrage là qu'il serait
prêt de petits et sur la con carne
ashrel à petit mécatina
est ce que ce serait insuffisant pour
changer la donne il y aurait assez de
nouveaux courants disponible mais on
peut en 2005 c'est faux faux réalisé que
c'était la tag la romaine à la romaine
s'est élancé en 2009 qu'elle est si
important de dos dont se passe elle doit
changer la face
long ça pouvait servir à certains
besoins qui restait sur jean pour
l'hydro quoique donne donc façon aussi
de le constater ce problème là mais sans
suite à ces joutes s'ajoute la
flexibilité l'aï drogue avec ça puis
j'ai pas dit qu'il pourra pas en avoir
deux ge golhen et celui là j'ai eu un
bon mais pas en même temps
c'est une bouchée à la fois notamment
berlin puis ça comme vous seraient ce
serait donc le premier ouvrage depuis
fort longtemps très bien merci beaucoup
de vos lumières jean thomas bernard